-Our next guest is
an Emmy and Academy
Award-winning writer,
producer, and director
behind movies like "Vice,"
"The Big Short,"
and "Anchorman."
His podcast, "Death at the Wing:
How Drugs, Tragedy,
and the Reagan Revolution
Defined a Decade of Basketball
is available
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify
or wherever
you get your podcasts.
Please welcome back
to the show Adam McKay.
How are you, Adam?
-Mr. Meyers, how are you, sir?
-I'm doing very well.
It's always nice
to speak to you.
We had the same job,
different times.
We were head writers at "SNL."
But I wanted to ask you
about a different title you had,
which you were the only person
ever to have that title.
I think you know
what I'm talking about.
Give us the backstory.
-Yeah.
So, I was head writer at "SNL"
for a couple years.
Had a wonderful time,
very challenging job.
And I kind of thought,
"Maybe it's time to move on,
and, you know,
in a very friendly way,
and my manager at the time
a guy by the name
of Jimmy Miller said, you know
"If you're gonna quit,
make an unreasonable demand.
And I said, "Well, I reall
want to direct films,
so I would love to have a budget
to do short films.
And I really don't like going to
all these production meetings,
so I don't want to go
to the meetings,
and I want a pay raise, and
want to name my own credit
And even Jimmy was, like,
"That's a lot."
And Lorne was like,
"Okay. You got it."
And so my credit
for my last two years
was "Coordinator of Falconry."
[ Laughter ]
And if you look at it,
they ran it towards
the end of the credits.
-Sure.
-But a friend of mine
got a frame grab of it
that I have framed,
but as far as I know --
and we'd have to dig
through the archives --
I believe I'm the only
Coordinator of Falconry
the show has ever had.
So, any time there were
loose falcons
that were gonna
fly in the studio...
-Yeah.
-...bring back prey to someone
with that leather glove on
they called me.
Now, unfortunately, that never
happened in the two years.
I never got that call.
-Right.
-But I was ready and trained
and I was ready to support "SNL"
in any way possible.
-So, this podcast
about basketball,
specifically basketball
in the '80s and how it sort of
intertwined the politics of that
era with the excess of that era,
and how, for a lot of player
in the league at the time,
it had very tragic outcomes.
-Yeah. It's a story
that I've been tracking.
I've been an NBA fan
or decades,
and through talking
to my friends,
we were always doing
the "what if" game.
We're like,
"What if Len Bias had played
What if
Drazen Petrovic had played?"
And it was all these
great talents
that all died very young.
Benji Wilson,
Terry Furlow, Hank Gathers -
it's an incredibly long list
And at a certain point, like
seven, eight years ago,
it was like, "Wait a minute.
Why did all these guys
die in this period?
I can't find this
in any other sport."
So the fun of, you know,
a podcast is,
you can kind of dive into it
with the question intact.
You know, if you sold this
as a TV series,
you'd have to already answer
the question.
But I was lucky enough, I go
these incredible producers
and we just dove in,
and what ended up happening was,
it became this portrait
of the '80s,
of the explosion of the NBA,
media, the Reagan Revolution
and all these kind of amazin
stories of these players.
-One of the things that I thin
people who are hyper-aware o
what professional athletes
get paid today
might be surprised to know
is how many athletes of that era
in the '70s and '80s
had second jobs.
-Yeah. It's weird.
Like, you think of basketbal
as this giant sport,
but in the '60s and '70s,
it was like the seventh sport.
It was like, football, baseball,
like, even to some degree,
bowling, boxing, hockey,
college basketball.
So, Jerry West -- we interviewed
the great Jerry West,
and he told me that he mad
$16,000 a year
after he was drafted, and he was
like the number-two draft pick
And I learned
from Jackie MacMullan,
the great sportswriter,
that Bob Cousy
was a driving instructor
during the off season.
And for people who don't know,
Cousy was, like,
a transformative point guard
you know, Hall of Famer.
And then, Tommy Heinsohn,
who was a forward
for the Celtics' great teams
he was a waiter
during the off season,
but he would chain smoke.
So he would come over to
the table with a Caesar salad,
and he would just reek
of Pall Malls,
and so they had to boot
Tommy Heinsohn.
And it kind of went on and on.
Bill Walton worked at the ASPCA.
He was neutering animals,
and -- all right.
That's clearly made up,
but the other ones are true.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, one thing, you know,
as we talk about, you know
legends of days gone by.
So, I'm coming up in Chicago
as an improviser
sort of in the era
right after you.
And I would always hear tell -
it was of legendary status -
the shows that you and your --
you know, your fellow
improvisers at the time
would do, not in theaters, but
out on the streets of Chicago.
Do you have any memories
of the street shows
you were doing as improvisers?
-Yeah.
It was
The Upright Citizens Brigade
which was our mangy little group
in Chicago,
and it was Horatio Sanz,
it was Matt Besser,
it was Ian Roberts.
Amy Poehler joined us.
We had Rich Fulcher,
all these different people
and there was one show we di
that was called
"The Conference
on the Future of Happiness."
And, essentially, we were al
these self-help gurus
who had promised that,
at the end of the show that,
you know, the fiction was,
every audience member
had paid $5,000
to come to this conference
and we had one sentence that
if you heard it,
you would get eternal happiness.
And at one point, my character
stole the sentence, and run --
ran out into the streets through
the real streets of Chicago,
and little did the audienc
know, my apartment was nearby,
and it was
a first-floor apartment.
So they chased me
to the apartment.
I busted into it like it wasn'
my apartment
and proceeded to murder
Horatio Sanz, who was watching
like, you know,
"Matlock" on his TV
and still had the sentence
and then came out the other en
of the walkway, and there wa
a car waiting for us
with bikini models on it,
and it was playing
"Everything is Beautiful"
blaring from the car.
And all of us --
Besser, Ian, Horatio --
got on the car and said,
"Do you want the sentence
of happiness?"
And the whole crowd yelled
"Yes!"
And we opened up a box,
and it was full of dough,
and then we whipped dough
at the audience,
called them a bunch of suckers
And I'll never forget
the main critic
from "The Chicago Reader,"
which you remember, Seth,
that was, like,
one of the big places
to get reviewed in.
-Yes.
-I think Jack Helbig
was his name.
-He was the guy.
-And I hit him dead center
right on his chest
with a big hunk of dough.
And then we drove away
with the bikini models,
leaving the audience, like
on some strange street
and just ending the show.
-And how was Helbig's review
-It was mixed.
[ Laughter ]
-That's fair.
That's fair.
Hey, thank you. It's alway
great to see you, Adam.
"Death at the Wing"
is available on Apple Podcasts
Spotify, or wherever
you get your podcasts.